j'accueille julie pietri
[Musique]
après du sourire avant veut
plus
fort
l'aventuré
non
il
alors
oh
la vedette qui ce soir a réussi son
retour
gagnant jeudi
après sa victoire dans l'émission retour
gagnant en 2003 ces arrêts six ans
quel plaisir quelle jolie salle un
passage remarqué au bataclan en 2007
[Musique]
la sortie en 2009 de son livre
témoignage sur les grandes étapes de sa
vie
en 2011 julie piétri rejoint la tournée
âge tendre et tête de bois c'est la
première saison que je fais avec instant
c'est un plaisir un donneur je suis
tellement fière
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tout le monde en a parlé
parti dans l'est de la france pour
retrouver julie piétri quelques heures
avant son concert je prends chez toi
tu m'a préparé ça l'est sud est
[Musique]
donc on est dans un casino à bussang
loin que nancy et voilà chez un garçon
chez lequel j'ai déjà pour lequel j'ai
déjà chanté
dans d'autres casino casino tranchant
notamment à yport deux fois et voilà
c'est toujours un moment de qualité à un
moment où on s'amuse bien et
où on fait des voix là on est accueilli
avec bonheur
avant son entrée en scène ce soir julie
tient à tout préparer l'artiste fait
c'est balance sous les yeux du directeur
du casino et de son équipe technique
et
oh
voilà la répétition est fait à temps
moudjar et j'ai faim j'en peux plus
je me demande un tonnerre et les cris
c'est l'heure la salle se remplit
jusqu'à la dernière place et c'est parti
pour deux heures de concert et de
bonheur pour la chanteuse aux plus de 12
millions de disques elle invite même le
directeur du casino à monter sur scène
avec elle le temps d'une chanson
[Applaudissements]
c'est une tradition pour elle à la fin
d'un concert julie mais peut partir sans
remercier son public
les plus forts mais pas vraiment génial
le haut
[Musique]
et après on prend la photo vous
inquiétez pas j'ai des photos de jouer
piétonne
mais c'est une chanteuse
surpris et j'ai bien parti m
aujourd'hui encore sa voix si
particulière
attire toutes les générations fidèle à
son public julie est aussi fidèle à son
équipe et à francine qu'il accompagne
partout je suis ce qu'on appelle des
oeuvres d'artistes
je m'occupe d'eux de az j'ai conduit
vérifiez que la scène soit bien
installée gens voient les bandes
les répétitions depuis trois ans tu veux
à faire une soixantaine de gala parents
ont fini par être complice c
c'est plus maintenant de l'amitié du
travail pas le temps de traîner julie un
avion à prendre direction les antilles
pour se transformer en actrice le temps
du tournage d'hôtel caraïbes sincérité
qui part très très tôt je dois refaire
vite ma valise on partira l'île saint
martin pour jouer dans cette série et
donc voilà quelques heures de sommeil
des bagages on fait comment peur mais
tout comme ça hambourg tout et on
reprend l'avion à roissy pour 9 heures
d'avion
bail
le
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
julie piétri julie bienvenue sur plateau
tu m'en a parlé vous êtes né le 1er mai
1957 à doué rats dans la banlieue
d'alger sous le nom de nicole juliette
pietri père xavier est dans l'agronomie
et votre mère denise et femmes au foyer
alors enfance assez traumatisante à
cause de ce qu'on a appelé les
événements d'algérie mais qui en fait
était une guerre vous dit les bombes qui
font exploser les vitres les corps qui
gisent dans les ruelles le sang qui
coule dans les rigoles ça vous a
profondément marqué partout dans le
monde je crois que ce que les gens qui
naissent dans une guerre sont marqués à
vie le tout est de transformer tout ça
en bonheur de vivre
alors autre cause du traumatisme
les rapports complexes que vous
entretenez avec votre mère en fait elle
n'avait pas connu sa mère à elle qui
était morte en accouchant et vous dites
chez les pietri on communiquait pas on
se confier pas on se plaignait pas
c'était très dur maman était né dans la
campagne d'algérie donc la campagne
d'algérie comme dans toute bonne
campagne surtout à une certaine époque
c'est quand même très très hard as été
élevé à la dure sans être aimé puisque
son papa l'avait accusé d'avoir fait
mourir sa maman voilà à l'époque les
césariennes n'était pas soigné y'avait
pas d'antibiotiques et c'est donc
c'était très très très lo et
voilà et mon papa travailler beaucoup et
chercher à nous protéger tout en
laissant un peu dans cette guerre
d'algérie qui je pense s'était pas faite
pour les enfants alors en 1962 après
l'indépendance de l'algérie comme des
milliers de pieds noirs d'être rapatrié
en métropole
votre famille transitent par la savoie
ensuite le petit quevilly votre père a
trouvé un emploi de commercial agronome
et là il retourne pendant quatre ans au
maroc dont vous vous retrouver de
nouveau en afrique du nord pendant
quatre ans ouais avec un grand plaisir
par
c'était c'était l'algérie sur la guerre
donc le maroc gaza s'étaient casablanca
on avait surtout ce folklore qu'on
aimait le mélange des cultures le
mélange des religions j'ai adoré être
là-bas malheureusement mon papa il a
très vite perdu un peu la tête et
pensant que j'allais voir le couvre feu
allez avoir des tanks ou des blindés
militaires ou qui allait avoir les
fellaghas enfin bon il était
complètement
traumatisée et quelques années plus tard
finalement tout est art surgi j'ai donc
vu mon papa est ce héros pleurer sur son
volant de voitures et donc là c'était
fichu il fallait rentrer son retour vous
vous installez opecst dans la banlieue
de saint germain en laye c'est là que
j'allais passer votre adolescence une
adolescence assez violente parce que
vous dites au lycée on me traitait de
sale arabe de sale juive le sale pieds
noirs de salles colonialiste c'est pas
facile pour les pieds noirs oui j'avais
tout c'était un multi mode comme ça
c'était du n'importe quoi c'est à
l'adolescence que vous décidez de
remplace celikkol par juliette qui votre
deuxième prénom et puis ensuite juliette
pas julie toujours à l'adolescence vous
commencé à vous intéresser à la musique
vous êtes incité par votre frère jean
qui vous amène à des concerts de jazz et
à 15 ans vous formez votre premier
groupe julie france
était bon il y avait quelque chose qui
m'échappe et à l'époque sur ce nom mais
bon moi je pensais aux avions et aux
salles d'eau salle de transit voilà et
donc c'était un bon groupe qui était pas
très heureux moi j'ai fait un peu marre
émission
avec avec la musique en oublier tous les
coups que je recevais au lycée parce que
j'ai pris quelques bons coups mais je
les ai rendu un
savoyard ' j'étais très bagarreuse ça
m'a vraiment appris à rendre coup pour
coup il ya peut-être à devenir un peu
une combattante dans le bon sens du
terme cette énergie là vous la mettre
dans la musique à mettre dans la musique
chantée du véronique sanson du janis
joplin
janis joplin joe cocker j'avais déjà un
voilage avait déjà dans l'idée que je
deviendrais chanteuse savait pas trop
comment oui parce que pour le moment
après le bac pour faire plaisir à votre
père est obligé d'obtenir votre diplôme
d'orthophonistes avant de continuer la
chanson quoi voilà donc papa m'a dit je
te coupe les vivres qui était déjà c'est
pas c'était pas l'ours qui me donnait
par semaine et s'il n'y a pas de ton
diplôme bah voila tu es tu es viré je
vais passer je les passais en même temps
je passer une audition pour entrer dans
un groupe voilà pour enfants 6 à l'arrêt
de la bande à basile oui absolument et
vous aller enregistrer un premier tube
qui s'appelle magdalena ça commence très
fort j'imaginais pas on avait été trois
solistes dont une fille du big bazar etc
à écouter cette maquette et les deux
sont partis les deux autres sont partis
en disant c'est vraiment de là où et ça
ne va pas du tout c'est très mauvais moi
je demande à réécouter cette maquette
jeudi mais ça me reste dans la tête je
sais pas si c'est ça que je veux faire
ma carrière je ne sais absolument pas
mais je trouve que c'est ça m'a l'air
très fort et j'ai fait ce premier ce
premier disque en disant moi je veux
bien faire un premier disque mais à
condition que si ça commence à marcher
je puisse avoir un album j'étais déjà un
peu roues et rusé et on va dire oui
d'accord ok ok ok puis puis moi je suis
parti à ibiza et puis pendant que
j'étais à ibiza il paraît qu on me
cherchait partout il y avait pas là il
n'y avait pas la technologie moderne y
avait pas de voile a pas de portable
avait rien du tout on va chercher
partout parce que
le dise commencé à fonctionner très bien
fonctionné c'est devenu un tube vous
fait l'olympia premier disque d'or et je
fais l'olympia grâce à monsieur sacha
distel qui me remarque qui aime bien
avoir un physique et qui m'a pris sous
son aile et là ça va bien parce qu'avant
votre gros tubes vous avez déjà vendu
six millions de disques avant celui qui
va marquer
les esprits durablement j'ai eu j'ai eu
voilà j'ai vendu six millions disent
qu'elles sous mon seul prénom je pense
que je rattraperai un peu plus tard je
m'appelais j'évite tout court julie tout
court ce qui me gênait beaucoup et là
c'est le carton de votre carrière eve
lève-toi numéro 1 au top 50 qui restait
classé pendant six mois ça c'est
vraiment le méga tube j'étais chez
claude carrière ça ne me convenait pas
j'ai tout larguer et y compris mais
royalties en le disant je veux récupérer
mon contrat je te laisse tout j'ai tout
laissé et j'étais à la recherche
d'autres choses y compris rechercher mon
nom de famille et retrouver mon nom de
famille comme nom d'artiste est vraiment
recherché mes racines au travers d'un
texte il me semble que je signe avec
jean-michel béria et on cherche un jeune
compositeur et ce jeune compositeur je
vais le trouver dans sa cave à enghien
les bains et là on a travaillé jour et
nuit et on a on a créé ce morceau eve
lève-toi et voilà et ça a été quelque
chose qui moi me convenait très bien
parce que ça me permettait de prouver
que je m'étais relevé des expériences
précédentes artistiquement et
voilà qui me montrait un peu comme la
combattante que j'avais toujours été et
surtout gertrude aussi non moins de
familles ce qui me plaisait bien ouais
c'est la célébrité quelles ont été les
réactions de votre entourage votre
famille déjà au la papaye déjà était
déjà convaincu que j'allais
que j'avais comme on dit j'ai les corses
tes stades que j'avais une testa douvres
voilà ce que je suis moitié corse moitié
pieds-noirs et c'est vrai que papa
trouvé que j'avais voilà un chemin
et que j'en parle jamais à personne et
que j'avais un chemin personnel j'ai
toujours été un peu comme un comment
vous dire un peu comme un électron libre
s'était jamais demandé conseil à
personne j'étais un peu solitaire une
artiste assez solitaire qui n'a jamais
fait partie d'une famille en particulier
ni d'un voilà j'ai jamais cherché à
avoir la carte pas avoir la carte je
m'en foutais et vos copains vos amis
je sais mais je savais j'ai très peu
goûté le succès de eve et de tout cet
album est toute cette période parce que
j'avais un sentiment beaucoup d'artistes
vous le diront d'être un peu pressé
comme un citron on saluera que je
sortais d'un drucker et on me mettait
trois bureaux 11 ans dans un coca cola
pour que j'aille rejoindre musiciens sur
scène à 100 bornes de là c'était
extraordinaire est à la fois j'avais
l'impression d'être sur une espèce de
nuages que je n'appréhendais pas
vraiment les médias ont été sympa avec
vous je vais pas me plaindre en fait
j'ai jamais donné vraiment beaucoup de
choses aux médias parce que encore une
fois je vous leur donnez pas à manger il
y avait peu à grignoter chez moi je
gagne l'argent non beaucoup et l'amour
est ce que cette célébrité vous a
rapporté des conquêtes ah c'est pas si
simple quand on est une fille quand on
est une femme on tombe sur le cac
figurent soit des mecs qui sont assez je
dirais pervers narcissique qui veulent
le pouvoir sur vous et qui n'accepte pas
que vous en ayez un peu
soit vous tombez sur des lâches qui fuit
en courant
je n'ose pas dire entre guillemets la
queue entre les jambes mais bon ça a été
plutôt le parcours là que j'ai eu dans
l'amour et voilà donc c'était ce n'était
pas facile que été le meilleur moment de
cette époque
plusieurs faits un olympia à guichets
fermés pendant huit jours parce que je
me suis rendu compte que si c'était
overbooké pendant huit jours la façon
dont je le prenais peut-être je le
retrouverais un jour
le pire moment le pire moment le moment
où j'ai fait une
virée entre guillemets une tentative de
suicide parce que mon compagnon de
l'époque avec lequel j'avais
cc ma relation ne supportait pas que ce
soit un simple enceinte ça sur le
producteur avec qui vous avez partagé
dix ans de votre vie voilà vous le
quittez vous rencontrer un autre homme
vous tomber enceinte mais lui va voir
celer en règle il comprend pas pourquoi
vous êtes enfin d'un autre quoi ces
sales histoires histoires ça qui m'a
proposé même le mariage une sorte de
trio ouais on a joué on aurait joué à
jules jim ah ouais moi je ne voulais pas
comme ça parce que j'avais vécu une
histoire très très très belle est à la
fois tragiques avec cet homme-là qui
était un peu pervers est un peu violent
et qui me harceler moralement mais avant
aussi mais à ce moment là ça a été une
horreur j'ai fait une tentative de
suicide
ce qui était que c'est une façon de dire
halte au harcèlement que de vouloir
vraiment mûri que je portais la vie
voilà j'imagine que quand on est
enceinte on annonce il est donc c'était
pour en finir avec les tourments qu'il
vous infligeant mais j'en ai eu marre
j'ai pris quelques médicaments trop ce
qui s'est passé donc tentative de
suicide le père du bébé vous trouvé
assez tôt pour qu'un lavage d'estomac
suffisent à vous sauver et malgré
l'effroyable pronostic de votre
producteur qui vous dit le bébé va
mourir ou bébé ne sera pas normal le
bébé est sain et sauf finalement voilà
elle va très bien évidemment j'ai tout
fait tout ce qu'il fallait à mieux
synthèse j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait
j'avais confiance en la vie me donner
cet enfant qui serait la seule je le
savais pas ce que au fond si j'ai envoyé
mon contrat chez sony c'est que le
monsieur qui m'avait
opéré j'ai fait la microchirurgie
pendant quatre heures et demie pour
avoir cette enfant
a suivi ma grossesse et m'a dit je te
signale que je vous signale que si
vous continuez à faire le des concerts
comme ça et à faire la route vous allez
perdre votre enfant à cinq six mois et
il en était pas question je savais que
je n'aurais qu'un enfant l'enfant va
bien l'info va bien elle est née
effectivement à huit mois seulement de
gros sacs ne c'est pas grave avec
quelques ennuis aux hanches etc mais
j'ai fait face je fais face pendant dix
ans alors là vous en train d'un avis ça
va durer neuf ans et vous comprenez en
fait que la guerre a laissé des traces
profondes et que c'est ça qui a exacerbé
votre vulnérabilité par rapport à à cet
homme entre autres oui je pense qu'il y
avait un côté
victimisation un idéal
pour régater 3 facile pour un homme
banal théorique est un peu abusif tout à
fait tout à fait je pense que voilà
c'est pour ça que j'ai souvent mais
pendant longtemps je vois de temps à
autres encore ben ben j'ai changé de psy
plusieurs fois mais ma chère madame
freud que j'aime énormément en fait
votre père quand il est allé au maroc la
guerre lui est revenue et vous c'est au
moment de votre pied canalise ou faire
monter toute ma grossesse à terme monter
à partir du moment où j'avais cette fait
cette tentative je dirais
de suicide entre guillemets c'est pas
vraiment ça que j'ai voulu faire mais
enfin bon
et que j'attendais cet enfant et qu'ils
avaient tous ces problèmes autour de moi
cet homme à peu près d'auteur me suis
posé des questions graves vraiment des
questions graves sur la petite enfance
sur pourquoi et là j'ai entamé un vrai
boulot j'ai aussi fait je suis rentré
aussi au cours florent pour voir si je
ne savais pas c'est autre chose que de
la musique voilà puisque j'étais j'avais
pu être orthophoniste je vous j'avais pu
être chanteuse je voulais savoir si
j'avais pouvait parfois aussi
être comédien louis alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes nostalgique de cette époque
deux élèves du ce a pas du tout
aujourd'hui pas du tout je trouve que je
vis bien mieux ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui et depuis que j'ai manon et
puis aussi depuis que je suis revenu à
un certain moment voilà vous avez de la
rancune contre quelqu'un et ce tome en
particulier je trouve que s'enfermer
dans des pensées négatives est quelque
chose qui me plaît qui m'intéressent
tellement pas ça m'empêchera d'aller de
l'avant déménageant je savais j'ai
j'adore les humains j'adore les de
découvrir finalement aujourd'hui j'ai
peut-être plus envie de parler que avant
mon analyse n'en voulait pas pas du tout
alors j'étais à refaire votre vie julie
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez pas pareil
la seule chose que je joue j'ai un
regret c'est d'avoir manqué comme dirait
laurent gerra d'un harnais avec moi ce
que je pense que j'aurais pu être une
une chanteuse plus
pas la chanteuse dont on dit elle a fait
magdalena elle a fait ça elle a fait ça
quelques en citant quelques étirements
de carrière après pense que j'aurais
même pu faire une carrière
peut-être peut-être mais bon c'est je
m'en fous quelque part aussi parce que
l'avenir m'attend l'avenir maintenant
j'adore le jour vous allez mourir que
tous les cons marque sur votre tombe et
on va rien marqué puisque je vais être
incinérés et que simplement j'aimerais
que maintenant en cachette à et du côté
de l'algérie la tunisie et du maroc à
répondre mais cendres dans la
méditerranée
merci je lis tous très heureux de
relever c'est aussi à vous mr scirocco
les clous voiture de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu